Relatively little is known about one
of Tesla’s most powerful executives.
Tom Zhu was Tesla’s chief in
China and the Asia region,
and he led the construction and
operation of Gigafactory Shanghai.
He’s been so impressive that in April 2023,
Elon gave him a huge promotion, to
senior vice president of automotive.
Where he’s responsible for
overseeing operations worldwide,
including all of Tesla’s assembly plants.
This makes Zhu the highest-profile executive
after Elon Musk, according to Reuters, which
reports that those answering to Zhu include:
the director of manufacturing at Giga Texas,
the senior director of vehicle operations and
manufacturing engineering at the Fremont factory,
the vice president in charge of
Europe, Middle East, and Africa,
and the VP of sales and service in North America.
The 43-year-old, who hails from Beijing,
obtained a Bachelor of Commerce in
Information Technology from the Auckland
University of Technology in New Zealand.
He then moved on to work at engineering
consultancy Kaibo Engineering,
founded by a Duke University MBA classmate.
The firm offers expertise to
Chinese contractors wanting
to expand infrastructure projects overseas.
While working for Kaibo in North Africa, he
was reportedly introduced to Cal Lankton,
the then director of Tesla’s
global EV charging infrastructure.
Impressed by his work, Lankton hired
him to join Tesla in 2014, to build
out Tesla's supercharging network in China.
Zhu has been responsible for Tesla’s
tremendous growth in that region.
Giga Shanghai went from a bare field in
January 2019 to a fully built factory in
just nine months and delivered its first
vehicle in December of the same year.
That’s despite battling typhoons
that hit the plant’s drainage system.
Zhu and other Tesla employees took
matters into their own hands and
went up to the roof to manually
drain the water with buckets.
Wu Wa, who documents the development of
Tesla’s Shanghai plant on his YouTube
channel, posted footage showing
the aftermath of the destruction.
Zhu played a significant role in
the quick recovery of the Shanghai
factory after COVID lockdowns in China
halted production for many companies.
And when a COVID surge led
to a two-month lockdown,
Zhu is reported to have slept in the factory
the entire time, safeguarding its operations.
On the rare occasion when he isn't at the factory,
Zhu resides in a two-bedroom public rental housing
unit a 10-minute drive from Giga Shanghai and
costs less than 2000 yuan, or $280, a month.
According to Chinese media, Zhu’s
parents have come to stay with him.
He keeps his private life private but
we do know he also has a young son.
Interestingly, the apartment complex is a
residential area for other Tesla employees
which he revealed in an interview with
the Chinese car review website, PCAuto.
“It’s a great atmosphere. Say,
you help me get my parcel,
I get something for you. It’s a
good way of working and living.”
He says he carpools with employees to the
Gigafactory and starts work at 6 or 7 am
in order to catch his colleagues in North
America before they head home for the day.
That includes communicating
directly with Elon Musk.
He spends the rest of his time on
the production line, talking with
engineers to solve technical problems,
and often doesn’t log off until midnight.
On his Chinese social media
account Weibo, he posted this:
“I wanna sleep so much, but the
job is so damn interesting.”
Zhu’s hard work has paid off.
He’s made Giga Shanghai
Tesla’s most efficient factory.
Its annual production capacity is over
750,000 vehicles which was more than half
of Tesla’s entire global production
of 1.37 million vehicles in 2022.
Giga Shanghai can currently produce
one vehicle in less than 2 minutes!
That’s still not good enough. Zhu says the goal is
to have a Tesla rolling off the
assembly line every 45 seconds.
Shanghai achieved its productivity by designing
the factory in a straight-line layout,
which simplifies the flow of materials through
the manufacturing process, increasing efficiency.
It also has a robust in-house construction team to
avoid relying too much on third-party contractors.
And the third factor is hard work.
Thank you for being here late at night.
Elon showed his appreciation
for Tesla’s China team when he
visited the country for the first
time in three years, in May 2023.
“I tell people throughout the world
the cars we produce here are not just
the most efficient production
but also the highest quality.”
I would like to congratulate you
on the amazing work that you’ve
done. It’s been incredibly impressive how you
have been able to overcome so many difficulties
and challenges. It warms my heart to know.
The Chinese government is a
strong supporter of Tesla,
which was the first foreign automaker
to open an independent factory in China.
Usually, foreign carmakers must
team up with a Chinese partner.
But some wonder if Tesla’s position
might be impacted by the escalating
tensions between the United States and China.
I think as long as we’re needed in this country,
I don’t see there (being) much of a risk of that.
Zhu has big ambitions for Tesla to grow
even faster - in China and around the world.
It took 12 years for Tesla
to build 1 million vehicles.
1.5 years to build its second.
11 months to build the third million
And only 7 months later, it built its fourth.
So we’re getting better at it
faster. Exponential growth.
In an interview with his alma mater Duke
University, he described himself as “tenacious”.
For his tenacity, he’s been handsomely rewarded.
Recently acquiring an additional 339,060
shares in TSLA, according to an SEC filing.
Given a share price of $214 when this video
was produced, they’re worth around $70 million.
Who knows how much they’ll be when he cashes out.
But for Zhu, it doesn’t appear to
be about the money. But the mission.
“Until all the cars on the road are
electric cars, we will not stop.”
If you’re inspired by Tom Zhu's
work in managing one of the most
sophisticated and efficient automotive
factories in the world, you might be
interested in boosting your understanding of
science, technology, engineering, and math.
That’s why I trust Brilliant, the website and
app where you can learn STEM interactively.
My viewers especially love Brilliant’s
computer science courses that can help
you stay ahead in today’s competitive marketplace.
There’s something for everyone,
whether you’re just starting out
or you’d like to progress to
their more advanced courses.
I personally go through Brilliant’s logic
courses to improve my analytical thinking.
If you ever get stuck, you click on ‘view
explanation’ to see where you went wrong.
You can try out Brilliant for FREE
for 30 days by heading to the custom
link in my description: brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 people who sign up
with my link will get 20% off their
Premium subscription, which gives
you access to all the offerings.
Thanks for watching. I’m Cindy Pom.